so you clicked on a fly lovemaking video
good choice
you're also in luck because this video
was sponsored by Full Sail Full Sail
University has a program about making
video games just like this one so if
you're interested in game development
check out the link in the description
now let's get into the fly business oh
yeah my flip flops are gonna fly all
over 50 lobbies but I'm so big now this
is awesome oh my god that fly is huge
where the [ __ ] did it go okay alright oh
my god stand still you're pissed yeah
that's where I got you [ __ ] I'm in the
bedroom baby you cuddle up beside me
right here are you doing take your shoes
off take your flip-flops off go to bed
they're off the raft
okay that's dead ass no one has ever
done this to me before
Oh slap it
oh that's my face that's too rough I'm
tired I'm leavin
but I love you there's a floating plugin
in the wall here yeah although BAM yeah
this registrated slepak a battery that's
what you get that's what you [ __ ] get
you piece of [ __ ]
alright let's do another one a spaceship
I'll be the ship's you're looking at
yeah that's that's a good choice
hey and every Flay Oh God hey anybody in
the fam you used to call me on my cell
phone
oh I can [ __ ] with objects too yeah oh
my god what are you doing there with
that laptop wait do you wanna have a
Bible we talking about
that's a definitely a laptop I heard it
up put it down ah my [ __ ] face you
like that you like that do you like that
that's right [ __ ] your cellphone you
[ __ ] with my face I [ __ ] with your phone
okay phone blah please I'm gonna go and
have children I'm gonna have a go ahead
and have bath uh-oh you got your phone
right here beside the bath oh this feels
good yeah I'm calling Katy Perry right
now can you pee you ever feel like a
plastic bag I do why don't you come in
and fill it with me
yeah hey baby you do it it's been a
while since someone Stephanie Rhea what
like my hipster shoes hard yes move what
is that Nike I love them a diva's [ __ ]
ah I'm sorry
do it again harder right another one
another one no we're not even late again
oh hey flight I see we're reading the
same book yeah it was on Oprah's list oh
my god I love all Pratt oh my god do you
want to read a passage with okay let's
Rick let's read a passage yeah I gather
okay oh you drop you sorry people I get
nervous when I read with someone so
handsome
it to my face hey where the [ __ ] did you
go hey hey baby
we're Oh God [ __ ] are you doing in my
face get away from me get away baby
alone Oh brah please
Oprah's not here to save me this time
now wait I can just I forgot your piece
of [ __ ] fly Oh God
you got a book fly to hell [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] they are here you'll never find
me
I wonder where you can be you never find
me here
got you between a [ __ ] ass I mean the
footwear you keep you whatever mmm I'm
just enjoying my hamburger what a great
day excuse me ma'am would you like
something to drink um yes a diet coke
please
a diet coke would you try to watch your
figure fat ass
oh my god that is so rude ah food fight
oh that's right give me my sprite zero
that's right let's leave it exist
baby the kitchen poop for the [ __ ] is
that fly man oh [ __ ] I hit got throw
fries in your face of entrance fries to
make myself feel better
oh but damn damn it
buddy what are you doing you can't come
back here
hey though they're this and then oh yeah
okay hey hey I'm sorry
hey hey you have a burger I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry okay okay however you're
yum-yum-yum-yum-yum
you never find me in here oh my God
where are you now and the closet fapping
oh thank you this time last level we're
gonna play it seriously
wait seriously whoever whoever loses
becomes the fly forever forever
oh it's is this a Breaking Bad factory
snitch
it's breakin to always to fly episode
the boss
oh hey to that episode so long and they
just had to kill fly I'm gonna make some
meth but about the way up it was that
noise oh my god Jesse Jesse there's a
fly Jesse I'm spirit ated you weren't
even here this episode it was just me oh
my god it's nice and cozy kids I can't
see it's just you how far does it and
then we say oh my ass I love you Oh God
not in the day oh god no wash me wash me
with chemicals I want to die please
lynnie highs win the flood what really
oh yeah
all right that was slap in the fly more
like fapping the fly
alright I hope you bros enjoyed that
video thank you so much to Full Sail for
sponsoring this video I think it's
really cool to have them be part of this
cuz if I love games you love games if
you're watching and if you're interested
in making games check out the link in
description if I could go back in time I
would have loved to I've done that I
think it's so cool and maybe I'll play
your game in the future leave like if
you enjoyed and as always stay awesome
press